à faible revenu vivait ici dans les
habitations du frêne dans le centre sud
de Montréal jusqu'en 2019 depuis
l'immeuble et barricadé jugé trop
insalubreuve il y a 15 ans
la Fédération des locataires réclame la
création d'un programme de 400 millions
de dollars pour rénover l'ensemble des
HLM sur 5 ans l'organisme reproche aussi
à la CAQ d'avoir détourné des fonds de
l'entente avec Ottawa destiné à la
rénovation pour financer plutôt la
construction de nouveaux logements c'est
pas normal qu'on utilise l'argent des
locataires de HLM qui méritent que leur
logement soit rénové pour construire
d'autres logements qui répondent à
d'autres besoins les parties
d'opposition soutiennent cette demande
c'est en train de s'accélérer la
dégradation et c'est vraiment inquiétant
la vérité c'est que personne Inexium de
ce gouvernement il est en train de
mettre en péril un actif le gouvernement
répond avoir investi d'importantes
sommes dans les dernières années
insuffisantes selon les organismes qui
ont des attentes élevés en vue du budget
le 21 mars prochain ici Jacques Audrey
Charbonneau Radio-Canada Montréal